in maths in maths disagreement and
arguments a really really important
really important in fact one of the one
of the topics I wanted to do that if you
have enough time is the history of maths
and it's just the history of people
arguing right but we don't really
encounter that much in normal Matt's
it's kind of like there's a right answer
if you don't get that answer you're
wrong in distorted right so we don't
experience the argument and the
discussion very much because we learn
the parts of maths that have already
been settled right except for today
except for today so today you're going
to be arguing about something here's
what you're going to Maddox is
mathematics about discovery or is it
about invention let me explain what I
mean you are going to be debating a
statement a statement is mathematics is
I better get the mathematics is
discovered not invented so it's gonna be
an affirmative this is gonna be a
negative you're now wondering why are we
in three groups I'll explain why in a
second okay now you get this on paper a
second okay now let me try and explain
what it's about so that when you go off
and create your arguments you have a
thought about okay what direction are
you let's think about this okay let's
think about rules or laws
okay rules or laws because in maths we
have these right uh in science in a
study of science we have rules we have
laws and quite emphatically they are
discovered not invented right really
this is about scientific observation
right now before Einstein came along and
said this it was already true didn't
need a human being to come along and
state it or define it he was a discovery
right or gravity or inertia or on and on
and on and on in science that's the way
it works okay
but that's not not all kinds of
knowledge alike that some knowledge is
invented and that doesn't mean it just
made up it's still very very important
for instance let's think about saying
the laws of a country or a government
right so sociology okay
that's those invented it's it's designed
it's crafted and that's why it's
powerful because some people really
really smart and who thought really
really hard they invented something with
power and elegance and it makes sense
right so you can have rules or laws in
the country but disturb it so we came to
Australian like oh there were laws right
no no it's not like that
was invented right that's where it's how
come so my question is which category is
massive is mathematics discovered or is
it invented